So here's spring, which is my favorite.
Oh, he looks pretty.
Wow.
He's really excited to be
dressed as a spring flower.
He's a beautiful boy.
Yeah.
How did Nolan never get around to this guy?
Well, we'll get to that. We will get to that.
Nina, what is the best and worst Batman villains
that you want to see on the big screen next?
So in the interest of remaining positive,
I don't have a best, but I have a worst.
Perfect.
I went with-
You did this the right way.
Yeah. I just wanted to dunk on a really bad
Batman character. So I am going to go with
a Calendar Man, who... Yeah, I thought that was
going to happen. Why do you think I wanted to go
first. So Calendar Man is a villain who
only commits crimes on specific holidays. He
absolutely sucks. That's his entire
gimmick. He did technically appear
in the Lego Batman movie, but we, the
Looper team, decided that doesn't count-
It doesn't count.
... because everyone was in the Lego
Batman movie. That was the point,
right? Everybody was in that. So I think that
would be just... I mean, I just don't want to see
a Batman villain being like, "Well it's Arbor Day,
so I killed somebody with a tree." I don't
need that kind of negativity in my life.
It is kind of a tough sell for a guy,
if his one weakness is being
locked in a room on specific days.
Yeah. And I mean, I think there's probably
a way that you could use him. I will admit
I have not yet watched the animated Harley Quinn
series, though I hear it's really, really good.
It is very good.
And apparently Alan Tudyk voices him in this
series, I believe. And I love Alan Tudyk. And
if anybody could play him on the big screen,
maybe it should be him. But I also really,
really don't want to see Calender Man pop
up in the DCU in live form at all, because
what a terrible villain. He's tied to a calendar.
You know when he's going to commit a
crime because there's a holiday coming up.
Okay. So I also picked Calendar Man.
I knew it.
Oh, guys.
I haven't gone yet. I'm just
co-opting because I have stuff
planned for Calendar Man. I
want talk about Calendar Man.
I love it. I love it.
So I've shared in our chat the
cover of his first appearance.
And his first appearance back in the '50s, created
by Bill Finger, Batman co-creator, Bill Finger.
He did crimes committed based on the
seasons. They weren't holiday specific yet.
Oh. Okay.
So his first appearance, he dresses up in
five different outfits. And the first one
is on the cover, or at least the
first one you see it's on the cover,
as you can see, he is dressed like summer.
So he's wearing an interesting outfit.
Oh, like a hazmat suit with
a sun in the middle of it.
It's really nice.
It looks great. I would like one.
It's intimidating, is what it is.
Mm-hmm. I'm scared.
So then this is, on page one of that
issue, this is what he look like.
He's dressed up like a snowman. And
so I should also point that in these,
both of these appearances, when he's
committing these crimes in this one issue,
he has different... So he's this genius inventor.
He's doing... He has heat powers where he's
shooting heat rays, and flames, and
things like that. And then when he's
dressed as a snowman, he's shooting snow, and
ice, and all that stuff. So winter, summer.
Well, I'm reading, just quickly, I'm reading the
page that you sent us and it is extraordinary.
I mean, things were different in
the '50s. Let's just be honest.
They're at a diamond exhibit, a thing
that definitely happens in real life.
I don't want to stop making fun of this, but I
will point out that the reason that it is this
ridiculous is because, after the Comics Code
Authority came through, and said, "Hey, these
comic books are corrupting the youth. You have to
make sure that kids are safe reading these comic
books." They were like, "Okay." So they basically
made them silly cartoons back in the '50s.
Sure, sure.
And it took many decades to
get a little crazier again.
I mean, that's an important thing to note,
right? That comics were silly for a reason.
Yeah.
So, okay. But anyway, back to how
stupid this looks. So I'm sending now,
I'm sharing his outfit for autumn,
which apparently was so lame that they-
What? Shut up.
... only show it from far away.
So that's autumn. And he has a big wind
machine. And he's throwing leaves at Batman.
He's throwing leaves. That's what he's doing.
He looks like an extra from Cirque de Solei.
Mm-hmm. And so, here's
my favorite one, but not the last one.
And you're asking, well, there's four seasons.
How could the fourth one not be the last one?
I'll get to that. Nina, thank
you for sharing your time-
Wait. Is one of them award season? Does he
dress up like a Golden Globe or an Oscar.
I'm sorry to say you're not as far off as I'd like
you to be. So here's spring, which is my favorite.
Oh, he looks pretty.
He's really excited to be
dressed as this spring flower.
He's a beautiful boy.
Yeah.
How did Nolan never get around to this guy?
Well, we'll get to that. We will get to that.
We're going to get to a lot.
So in this issue, he's basically committing
crimes, and he's taunting Batman. He's like, "I'm
going to commit five crimes," and he's dressing up
as these four seasons. And Batman and Robin can't
figure out what the deal is. And then eventually
they figure out what the fifth season is.
And they figure it out by seeing this clue in
the paper, Calendar Man dresses up as an
Indian magician with a turban, and says that the
fifth season is monsoon season, and he was going
to steal some stuff, I guess, using rain. And
it's a pretty... It's kind of problematic. It's
not really great. Oh, yeah. And my favorite part,
I forgot. Yeah. So you're all in shock, but okay.
So how do you think that Batman defeats Calendar
Man. This is actually beautiful and amazing.
I get to assume using
clues from a far side calendar, like one of
those daily things, maybe two sassy cows.
Does he just get... I don't have a
good joke. Tom, you keep riffing.
I'll vamp. Okay. Let's see. He waits
for the mall where a calendar man is
working to shut down. I got nothing.
No.
How does Batman defeat this nefarious foe?
Does Calendar Man forget to write
down their battle in his calendar.
He literally throws a calendar at
him. He just throws a calendar at him,
and it hits him in the legs, and he falls down,
and then it's over. That's how that issues ends.
I'm going to start doing
this against my own enemies,
is just tossing wall calendars
at them and seeing what happens.
If you toss a giant wall calendar at someone,
a big one that's on a Blackboard, and you just-
Oh, that kind. I'm thinking like-
... throw it right at the backs of their knees...
No, it wasn't a little wall calendar.
This is like a big, big calendar.
I was thinking like pugs in dresses or something.
Mm-hmm.
One of those little like novelty
calendars, word of the day.
So yeah. So anyway, that's how Batman
takes out the Calendar Man. Now-
With his own-
With his own calendar.
He uses a calendar. Yeah.
So it's-
Well, he who lives by the calendar must also-
So he's hoisted on his own calendar.
Get hit in the legs. Yeah.
Oh, outstanding.
So first of all, it's actually pretty clever.
Why do I like comic books?
Second of all, that is not the
end of Calendar Man's story.
Certainly not.
How could it be?
Have either of you read
Batman, The Long Halloween?
Certainly have.
Nina, do you know this one?
I have not, but I know something about it that
I'm sure you're going to arrive at momentarily.
Yes. Which is that he shows up in The Long
Halloween as, basically, a consultant that
Batman and Commissioner Gordon talk to, to
figure out who this new Holiday Killer is.
Holiday.
So in The Long Halloween, every month goes by,
and a holiday comes up, and a serial killer is
out there bumping off criminals, and being bad
and, committing crimes. And so they're just like,
"Let's talk to Calendar Man. He
might know something about this."
And it's the only time that Calendar
man's been cool and interesting.
He does show up in the, I
believe, it's Batman, Arkham City.
Yeah.
I don't think he's in the first one. But he
shows up and he's just basically inspired by
this different look of a bald creepy weirdo who
is in a cell, who is obsessed with calendars.
And he's got the little months all
around. He's carved them into his head.
Yeah, that's in the second one.
Yeah.
The Dark Victory. He shows up with that
tattoo situation. But at the end of the day,
as far as I know the only interesting use of
Calendar Man, and it's only to be involved in
discussing the crimes of someone who does the same
thing as him, but better and more interestingly.
I got to say, that's my favorite trope in Batman
comics, is that if somebody shows up and
starts committing a very specific crime, they're
always like, "Well, the only person who could have
any insight into this is this lunatic. This guy
committed a crime while he was asking questions,
so we should go talk to the guy who only wears
bowler hats, and has a cane that spins around."
Everything's a riddle. Yeah. No, you're
right. He's probably got some really great.
Yeah, yeah. He probably has some
really unique insights. Also, Brian,
I'm guessing you're aware that they're, in
March of this year, they announced a two part
Long Halloween movie in which
Calendar Man will appear.
So it's, it's for sure official
that he is actually going to appear?
I mean, in March of this year,
Hollywood Reporter set the voice cast,
he'll be voiced by an actor
named David Dastmalchian.
Oh, the polka dot man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know how to say his name. So,
we're going to get on screen. We're going to
have them say this is how you say his name.
Yeah, yeah. They'll correct
us. Yeah, ,we need that.
Maybe we'll maybe we'll take a break and we'll
have someone say his name in voiceover right here.
David Dastmalchian.
That's how you say it. I didn't know.
I always suspected that that was how you said it.
That was amazing.
Right. Exactly. So now that
we know how to say his name-
Yeah. I mean, I was close. Yeah.
I mean, that's a really great pick. But will
this movie be on the big screen or it's animated?
It's an animated movie. So that's
why I went with Calendar Man, because
as of right now, there are, unsurprisingly,
no plans to have a live action, big screen
villain be Calendar Man. And apparently he
was supposed to be in Gotham, which is also
not big screen. It's a television show, but
that did not happen. And I can't imagine why.
They were just like, "Yeah, Calendar Man is
still somehow too ridiculous
for this ridiculous TV show."
Yeah. They were like, "This is
the very bottom of the barrel,
and we've got other scrapings to pull of."
The Mad Hatter, for example.
Exactly.
Somebody much less ridiculous.
So that is my pick. And I'm glad
that Brian had so much insight because
it was also his pick. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I felt like I
stepped all over your choice.
Oh, no. Please. I need the Brian
Ruben comic book lore wisdom-
There it is.
... to back up my point
about why Calender Man sucks.
Calendar Man does sucks. He sucks. And-
Yeah.
Teamwork makes the dream work, Brian.
I feel, didn't they give Calendar Man crazy
superpowers recently. He sheds his skin,
and hatches a new body out
of his old carapace. Is this-
I will say I have no idea, but I will also say-
Okay.
That's wild.
... that given recent DC comics developments,
that would not surprise me at all.
Do you think anybody's done
a Calendar Man story where he
gets overwhelmed by the number of just stupid
social media holidays that are happening now,
where he's just killing someone every single day
because he's like, "It's National Waffle Day."
Talk Like A Pirate Day.
Right, yeah. He's at a Spirit
Halloween store every day,
just picking out new crappy
costumes, just trying to catch up.
That's a good way to defeat him. You invite
them to your Facebook. You invite them as a
Facebook friend, and you just start filling
the calendar with different stupid holidays.
Oh, man.
Just let him.
He'd be totally overloaded. He'd
never be able to get all that done.
Yeah. And he'd just be too tired. He'd
be like, "Oh, forget it. That's fine."
I'm tired just thinking about it.
I love it.
Do you think he ever tries to confuse
Batman by going with lunar calendar?
And like, "What holidays are these?"
Oh, no.
Chinese holidays. Jewish
holidays. Look out Batman.
Yeah.
I love this.
I think we should be hired to
write this. DC should call us.
I mean, now I'm ready to see them on the
big screen. I think it's going to be great.
Yeah, because we've got a cracker jack idea.
It's Lent, Batmen.
Yeah.
Okay. That's enough about
Calendar Man. What else we got?
The tag line for that would be,
"I'm giving up Batman for lent."
Yeah.
Anyway. Go on.
Tom, who do you have?
Okay. For me, I don't know, I'm of several minds
about this one, because I love Batman. I love
Batman since I was a kid. The villains are always,
if not the best part, then the dorkiest part.
And I think they really only fall into those two
categories. They're either just so cool or the
absolute worst. And I think both of those things
have merit. So my number one choice for the best
villain that I would love to see brought into
the big screen, and especially if we're going
to keep going grim with it, the way that it seems
like the Robert Pattinson movie is going to go,
I would love to see King Tut. Specifically
I would love to see King Tut done,
basically exactly the same way that
they did him in the '60s TV show.
If you're not familiar, King Tut was the
guy who got hit in the head with a brick,
and then woke up... This is true. None of this
made up. I mean, it's all made up. It's Batman.
He got hit in the head with a brick. He woke
up convinced that he was King Tut and then
somehow managed to finance this extravagant
lifestyle entirely based around hiring goons to
dress up as his underlings. And it's all ancient
Egyptian theme. He makes a jackal god statue. And
it's made out of solid gold with booby
traps built into it. And he releases
it in Gotham just hoping the Batman's
going to show up. I would love to see-
That sounds great.
... that level of... It is great,
Nina. I'm glad that you recognize that.
I think this could be Oscar bait.
Absolutely, yeah.
So do we agree about who should play King Tut?
Steve Martin?
That is the answer I was
looking for. Thank you, Nina.
I was hoping that someone was going to say it.
And he's older now, so he could play
it really creepy. Just spinning-
Yeah, yeah. But also exactly like he did on SNL.
Yeah. Just a lot of this, a lot
of the funky Tut, but he's old-
Big goofy.
Yeah.
... and kind of like terrifying in that way.
Yeah. I've always wanted to see Steve Martin in a
Batman movie. So this is how
I make my dreams come true.
It's the only way.
Let's make it happen.
Yeah.
We all have, Nina.
King Tut.
And again, he's another one that he showed up in
the Lego Batman movie, just as a side gag thing,
but the guy who originally played him, Victor
Buono I think was his name, just, I mean, he's
the same as everybody else who did stuff on the
old Batman series. He's just chewing scenery the
whole time. Just these grand role. And yeah, no,
so I don't know. Something about inserting that
into this very self serious franchise that just
cannot stop trying to convince us that a story
about a rich guy who dresses up as his favorite
animal and punches people is worth our emotions.
Was King Tut also in the comics?
No. They made them specifically for the show. He's
shown up in the comics, again,
as a gag character since then.
Got it. Okay. All right.
But no, he's just delightfully the worst.
I support that idea.
I love it. I think it's a
great pick. I want to see it.
If we are going to go just straight dark. I
think that Professor Pyg would be a great option.
Okay. Yeah.
Creepy character.
Do you want to tell us about...
Professor Pyg is a relatively new
addition to the Batman Rogue's Gallery.
Well, that sounds dark just from the name alone.
It's one of those things that sounds
kind of ridiculous when you just say it
absent of any context. But Tom, do you want to
explain who Professor Pyg is and what his deal is?
I want to say they came up with him for one
of the cartoons, but I'm positive that we'll
put in a snotty caption underneath me if
I'm wrong right now, just correcting me.
I will correct you now. Based
on my understanding of it,
I believe that he was invented by
Grant Morrison, I want to say maybe-
You know what? I think you're totally right.
... 15 years ago when he took over and Professor
Pyg was one of the early villains that he did.
They don't really set him up
very much, but he's just this
creepy guy wearing a pig head
who does weird experiments.
Actually, can we get the caption
correcting the anyway? Or just calling me.
No, I want to... Yeah.
Cool.
Wait. I have a question about Professor Pyg.
Okay. What's your question?
Was he also hit in the head with any bricks?
That's a valid question.
Inevitably, right? I mean, that is kind of place.
Because the context of this is important to
me. I am a scholar of this. I'm learning.
Yeah.
How many bricks are responsible for
the origins of Batman villains? How
many times were they hit in the
head and then something happened?
That's what I need to know.
This is what the people-
Oh. So the masons are actually
responsible for crime in Gotham.
Oh my God. You can't say that in the
video. They're going to come for us.
It's not that far from the Court of Owls. I think
we got this pretty much figured out. Anyway,
the idea is he's based on the myth of Pygmalion,
and his whole goal is that he wants to turn
people into their perfect forms, which he does,
obviously, by chopping them up. And making them-
I was wondering how we were going
to get to Pygmalion from that.
Mm-hmm. P-Y-G.
Yeah.
Hey. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a stretch, but no, I
mean, Grant Morrison's a weird guy.
It is a stretch.
It'll be probably, I would wager that they'd
probably bring him into a movie in maybe another
10 or 20 years. He hasn't been around
long enough to be a classic character,
but I wouldn't be surprised if he joins-
Do you think they would change his name
because Professor Pyg does sound so silly.
Do you they would came up with
something that sounds menacing?
I mean, in Dark Knight they had
the Joker, they had the Riddler.
Cool.
And it's basically Jigsaw stuff.
I mean, everyone... Yeah, but everyone
knows who the Joker is. No one was like,
"That doesn't sound like a real villain."
I think if you pair some of the visuals
of Professor Pyg in the marketing,
and you don't have to go out of your way to
say in this movie Batman fights Professor Pyg.
Sure, sure. Yeah.
It'll still be creepy and menacing
enough that you'll probably...
Yeah. I think it would
work. I think it would work.
You get the overhead lighting and
the... Yeah, too many shadows.
I'm just here to make 30 Rock references.
And all I'm thinking about is when Jenna Maroney
is filming a low budget horror movie in Stanford,
Connecticut, and there's a guy
in a pig mask torturing her.
It's basically exactly that.
And they're talking about their great
public libraries. That's what I'm
envisioning. So that's fine. I can
roll with that. That sounds good.
Well, so now we know that
it works. It can be creepy.
Yeah. Yeah.
You just need the right context.
Thanks, Tina Fey.
Perfect. So my pick for worst was Calendar
Man. My pick for best is the Ventriloquist.
I think it would be-
No it's not.
Yes it is. I think he's fantastic.
No!
No? You don't agree.
I'm into it.
Make the case. You have the floor.
Okay. So the Ventriloquist is basically, I love
this idea, because he is a person who's basically
so... His identity is so fractured that all
of his aggression, and anger, and malevolence
is channeled through a ventriloquist
dummy, which is dressed up like a little
gangster man. And he is literally the gangsters
right hand man, because he's got his hand in the
gangster. Everyone knows that the Ventriloquist is
the person controlling the puppet, and yet the way
in which they're portrayed makes it menacing
enough that they are two separate characters,
the Ventriloquist and Scarface. And it's so
strange of an idea, and so simple, and classic.
I love it because it really hearkens back to
Batman was created in 1939, he was inspired by
The Shadow. And so you've got these great pulpy
villains, these bad guys, like the Joker, like
Two-Face. These are characters who we've all
come to accept as classic Batman villains.
And you've got this dude, the
Ventriloquist, who's created in the '70s.
And he just belongs in that old school, old style,
pulpy Batman, bad guy villain. He is legitimately
menacing and creepy if done right. And I just
think it fits so well with Batman's villains,
weird, strange predilections for obsessing on
singular things. And I love that this guy is weak,
and yet he's still the bad guy. He's ultimately in
control. And I think that they could do a really
good job with it. Going off of your idea, if we
were to get a sequel to the Matt Reeves' Batman,
throw the Ventriloquist in there, just some nut
who carries this dummy around. And I love how they
did it in the Batman animated series. I know I've
been talking a long time with no one interrupting,
and that's a little worrying, but that's
okay. I'm just going to keep going because-
Well, you've sold me. I'm going to interrupt
you and tell you that you've sold me.
No, because I find ventriloquists
creepy a lot of people do.
Ventriloquists are super creepy.
I don't like them.
In the original, in the Batman animated series
from the '90s, they did a story with that.
And before you know that it's a ventriloquist
with a dummy, you just think that there's
some little tiny gangster who's in
control, who's being carried around-
Oh, I hate that.
... by this man with glasses.
And then eventually you find out-
I'm not familiar with that story, and I never
want to be familiar with that story because-
It's great.
I like sleeping at night.
It's super good. So-
Nina, did you just ew somebody being tiny?
Tom, shut up.
I'm just, I'm worried about you is
all. Seems like a self loathing thing.
Yeah. Well, I'm not
masquerading as a tiny gangster, who's
being operated by a meek sidekick, and I-
Not yet.
We don't know that about you.
Who knows what's going to happen next week,
next month. It might happen. But anyway,
that's my pick. I really like the ventriloquist
as a concept. I'm not going to say he's one
of my favorite characters, but he is a
super weird one and he's pretty obscure.
I think that's also good, because I
don't think... I doubt anyone was like,
"Scarecrow would make a great creepy villain."
Right.
And he does.
So I don't see why Ventriloquist
couldn't work as well.
And it's the kind of thing where it only-
Because Nolan made Scarecrow really creepy.
Yeah. And it's a totally, it's a very
grounded, in a way, grounded character.
There's nothing supernatural. There's no
super powers going on. It's just someone-
Yeah. I like that.
Yeah. It's just this really great gimmick for this
villainous character. And I
just love it. So that's my pick.
Tom still seems unconvinced.
Tom?
I guess what I'm struggling with is the
physicality of the character. How do you make an
imposing threat-
I don't know.
... if his whole thing is that
he's a doughy guy with a puppet?
Have you ever seen a Jeff Dunham standup special?
I have. And I've also seen a
lot of people who were very
eager to punch him afterwards. I don't understand.
Exactly. What a great villain.
All right. Yeah. Nope. Sold.
I got it.
I'm in.
Also, sorry Jeff Dunham. I have
nothing against you. I feel bad,
because I know that he's watching.
Yeah, he's been every week.
He's a huge fan.
He's a big Looper fan, Jeff
Dunham. And watching too.
Thanks for watching. Please hit like and
subscribe. So you don't miss a single video.